vade org
and beginning now on book TV on c-span 2
here's actress Diane Guerrero her book
is in the country we love this is book
TV on c-span 2 live from the Texas Book
Festival
Oh
bienvenido suppose howdy
it is your textbook festival right
I am honored to be your moderator today
those of you in Austin may recognize me
my name is olga tempest formerly
broadcast journalist here in town now
working in the world of philanthropy
raising money thank you
it is my pleasure to welcome you today
to the c-span tent
we love the rain don't we we love our
guest author who this year that's who we
really love so let me just tell you
briefly about her if you don't already
know you must because you're filling
this can't today
she's an actress who's currently
featured in a recurring role in the very
successful hit show orange is the new
black now in its fourth season that were
not wearing our 55th season already well
it's a I need to do some more binge
watching she's also engaged a virgin
which can be seen on a CW channel even
had a great show yeah she's also busy as
a volunteer with a non-profit immigrant
legal Resource Center and with me
familia vota she has also been named an
ambassador for citizenship and
Naturalization by the White House she
lives in New York City and she is among
our featured authors here at this year's
Texas Book Festival she joins us now to
discuss her book in the country we live
my family divided let's give a big Texas
welcome to Diane nettle well
hi guys I'm so happy to be here at this
time in Texas and Austin is wonderful
what did you say - huh okay thank you I
like it keep it keep it real she was at
the gala last night I can't hear
anything
yeah I'm deaf from last night I had a
little bit much fun much fun and it's
good okay all right got anything so we
we want to get to the heart of her book
and if you've read it raise your hand so
we have some so you'll know where I am
when I'm asking these questions if you
for the five people liver and but all
the people who are going to buy it and
go to the book signing afterwards right
okay so the book opens with the day that
and we waited I need to tell you that
we've already gotten Kleenex is handed
out to us because it is that emotional
you're welcome the book opens with the
day that you come home and your life is
forever changed your parent your parents
are gone
yeah there were some stark memories from
that day share with us what you remember
from that day and what you regret well I
had just started it was my first year in
high school and it was really a special
time for me because I I struggled in
school in the past and I also I the
school that were available to me they
were tough there was very tough schools
and very tough neighborhoods and you
know I was little and like kind of wimpy
and like I could you know I really
couldn't defend myself no that's that's
a joke I know I really didn't I couldn't
but that's not
I was so scared to go there I was scared
because I I felt like I would be just
lost in the cracks and I wouldn't get
the education that I needed especially
for someone who had difficulty learning
and picking things up and I really like
the arts and I felt like I needed a
creative space to really flourish or
really understand things like history in
English and math I needed a creative
space so I was really afraid to go to
just a regular public pool around the
hood because um you know it was scary a
lot of kids didn't pay attention a lot
of you know it was hard for teachers to
control classes and I needed something
more because I had a I had a vision of
being something more than what was
offered to me so I finally a Chancellor
suggested that I I auditioned for this
pilot school performance arts high
school so anyway I got in I got in the
music program and I was a very special
time and sort of saw my life is looking
up around that time or for many years I
had lived in fear with my parents
because they were undocumented and that
was our reality for a long time and
that's all we talked about you know what
the lawyer is saying and did the papers
come in or did you file this paper
correctly and you know who down the
street this person said they got their
papers and we know why are we still in
this position so that was the kind of
trauma that I heard for a long time um
anyways that day in particular my mother
was on me she wanted me to have
breakfast and I was late to school and I
didn't like to be late to school
especially at school that I really loved
and we had a huge fight that morning so
when I got home
you know I the whole day I realized that
this fight with my mother and I'm like
my mother was just trying to feed me why
would I have this petty fight with her
and I was so angry you know
like I am so angry but happy and but I
don't want to share that happiness with
my mother and father and you know I was
15 year olds often dear 14 year olds
often do um yes so when I got home it
was I was ready to tell them about the
great day that I had and I was going to
say sorry to my mother actually like
stopped by I wouldn't you like to get my
dad my dad had given me 50 bucks you
blown the law he won the lasting 1/8
like it was not a lot of money but he
won the lottery and it looks like it was
you know it was a sign that things were
looking up for us you know because we
were always so worried about money Aaron
so he gave me $50 that day so I stopped
by needed some new kicks and then some
new sneakers and I stopped by bought
from adidas shell-toes now it's a nice
program we have it and yes so but but I
would still you know I was still worried
about that fight that I had with my
mother's when stopped by a payphone and
most of the time like ever you know
people didn't really have I mean some
kids had cell phones but I mean I sure
as hell didn't so I stopped by a
payphone and I put a quarter in I tried
to call my parents and it was I was only
a block away and I just wanted I was so
desperate to tell my mother that I was
sorry that I loved her and that I didn't
want to fight with her and then I was
coming home soon I'm a mom I'm a block
away from there but I was feeling I was
feeling all sorts of emotions anyway I
walk in and and they're gone and then
the neighbors came and told me that they
that they had been taken away by ice
that immigration would come and I take
him away and and that was really hard
for me as a 14 year old and
seeing that my mother's dinner was
started the rice and the beans would
started and they were gone I was really
sad that that day I know in the book you
say you regret that you regret the pies
I do and you try to remember everything
that led up to that day but it was a
turning point not just for you for your
family for your future following that
tell us a little bit about the struggles
that the deportation the in-and-out the
meetings of lawyers tell us a little bit
about how that impacted even your
feelings about leaving the house leaving
your neighborhood
it just it's like you were living under
like we here living under a shadow
living in the shadows
yeah I mean it was it was really scary
to go out there and face people you know
I we had kept this secret for so long
and now you know my folks were gone and
I was here by myself and I felt like I
needed I didn't really know what to do
nobody came to check on you no no no one
came I waited I did wait you know I
well at that moment I I pried and it was
upsetting and then I my dad had mentally
prepared me for a long time my dad was
always like a doomsday kind of guys
still is and so he would say you know
when the day comes I'm like dad why are
you saying that like stop saying that
you're going to die Sutton that I might
walk in one day and you won't be there
um but dad was a realist and he's like
well this is our reality and this is
what we're living with so he had
mentally prepared me and told me what to
do and so right after that I said okay
Diane you need to think quick what are
you going to do and so I just I just
picked myself up I I got the phone and I
called on
some close friends and they came over
right away and we waited there to see if
any government official would come we
didn't want to further who push the law
but no one no one came so I I saw no
other option but to go with them and
stay with them until I got a call from
someone so here you are 14 you finally
are in a school the Boston Academy of
Arts is that correct
a Boston aren't ya I start getting
thriving as a young young adult but with
this heavy burden that you're facing
yeah how did your life move forward were
you able to maintain your school your
your creative outlet
yeah I was very determined I mean I I
mean at that that day I made the
decision to to stay I mean I could have
a lot of people go well why don't you
just go with her family you know why are
we here
caring about this why didn't she just go
with her family and and all you know and
it's not our problem anymore but I am an
American citizen I was born in New
Jersey and the u.s. is all I know and
I've never been to Colombia um so and I
just I didn't see any other option and
my parents didn't really have a lot of
money you know in Colombia it's really
hard to do anything if you don't have
the money and and the status so I was
going to go to the unknown and I I
needed I needed to school Boston as I
saw as my outlet as my ticket out so I
decided to stay and further my education
and you know fight it fight fight the
good fight on my own and so I could
eventually make my parents proud or make
something of myself and hopefully and
maybe bring them back one day I don't
know one of the passages in the book
that touched me was your involvement in
a car accident
yes and share with us what happened
after that
that was influence because of the
deportation well I felt like I couldn't
I didn't like to rock the boat and I was
very I mean I was very quiet I was
staying at a friend's house you know I
had to be I couldn't want for anything
I didn't feel like I deserved anything
and I also if something happened to me
or if I got sick I would be scared to
tell anybody about it um so yeah one day
I went to the store and I got hit by a
car and um I didn't tell anybody about
it
I just I got up thank God I mean I
wasn't I mean I had some later on I I
found out I broke my wrist and had some
sort of like internal bruising but like
nothing else but like I was like limping
back home but I didn't want to tell my
friends because I was afraid that they
would make me leave or that I wouldn't
have a place to stay because they were
nervous about keeping me so I wanted to
have my place and a lot of us go through
that when you're alone I would have your
parents and and you're trying to survive
but yeah I mean later on I of course I I
told them because my wrists hurt so bad
the fact that you didn't want to seek
medical attention for fear of the
consequences at the heart of things
okay I wasn't like in a speaks volume
for just that hesitancy that that ruled
your your action yeah so that to me and
you have to wonder how many other young
youngsters they are left behind you or
disappear today right yeah what what
other attention are they missing out on
are they fearful of seeking all right
tell us about visiting your your mother
when she was being held through this
deportation process because it seemed
like for a young for a youngster a
fourteen to have to go visit a parent
who's incarcerated
is not an easy experience to face no it
was difficult because I didn't see my
mother as as a criminal I'm sorry very
hardworking and I saw her as my mom so
going to see her in jail was was
difficult and I don't know you know I
didn't know the things about prison as I
do now
obviously weird house has colors of life
or I'm like really I mean I agree I'm
really grateful for the work but I'm
like so yeah I was scary it was scary to
be there into my mom this way and see
her
so at such a low point and all she
wanted to do would be with me and all I
wanted to do is be with her and I was
just I was I was just really angry
well that anger if I understood
correctly led to some alienation there
yes big time yeah I am and that that's
not easy because I mean as a mom myself
of twin daughters they fight you when
you're around at 14 but you know they
want you there and then you have
somebody else in this fight you've got
the government is there creating a
battle between you and your mom put one
right there in your lap and you're in
your living room for you so let's talk
about moving beyond that and because
there was so many years that transpired
from when they were deported yeah to
your continued education your schooling
you're living with other friends how did
that how was that still just always
present in your life well I did what a
lot of people do is I buried it deep
deep deep inside
and a lot of I suppress a lot of my
anger and sadness and I also avoided my
parents so I wasn't talking to them or
taking any phone calls and I blame them
for everything I was angry and you know
continued I was voted most
happy-go-lucky in school no that isn't
seriously so no one knew that I was
going through all of this no it was very
quiet about it of course you know when I
got to college then I decided to be
crazy and let it all affect in very
negative ways well that's another
chapter - yeah that is another chapter
well you know when when you know
politicians don't tell you about what
happens you know to the family what
happens to the children and you know
that that hurt that pain and and doesn't
end that day that your parents or your
family is a separator taking away last
four years and I've I've had um I need a
lot of therapy and I still see some line
which is so important and mental health
is something that we often don't talk
about especially in like in the
communities that I grew up in you know
you're not allowed to be upset or sad
it's like your art is are your limbs
okay or you like not sex you're good you
know just dust off go clean something or
go eat you're not allowed to be sad it's
like a you know it's a first-world thing
and even if you're living in one you
know it's not for you it's for people
with money and who have cozier lives
than you you're not allowed to to be
upset but but I learned a lot about
myself of course and and therapy allowed
me to be here right now because I had I
had huge issues and on that point I
think we like to take a reading from
your book because in this passage that
we're going to listen to Diane read it
presents a clear vision of of how she
saw herself yes and also in my book the
five people who read it know that I have
far so far exactly know that I have it's
hard for me to is funny because I chose
I chose to be an actor because I was
like yeah I totally want to be an actor
and it holds a lot of reading and evolve
you know a lot of cold reads and stuff
like that so it's hard for me in a table
read not to take my time I'm I'm like
mildly dyslexic and I struggle with that
learning disabilities but here we go
meaning don't make fun of me okay let's
all respect each other okay oh wait this
is my fault page was out here we go I'm
like okay
during our months together Lorraine gave
me many gifts Lorraine was my therapist
the time and one of the greatest came
during this session in the summer of
2009 I was telling the rain again about
all the ways I dropped the ball all the
stupid decisions I've made all the times
I'd let myself and others gown usually
she let me vent fully before she spoke
on this day she interrupted me rude you
want to know something Diane she said
what I answered surprise she'd cut in
you are not your mistakes
Lorraine stared at me for the longest
time as that sentence hung in the air
between us I lowered my head fiddled
with my bangle bracelets and looked up
at her again your failures don't suit
your failures I want to say do not and
then I said don't all right your
failures Tom's defying you she continued
your worst isn't about what you do or
don't do you have value simply because
your he is I drop my eyes to the floor
and let that sink in I spent my entire
childhood trying to be the good Catholic
girl trying to earn the approval of
others trying not to make mistakes my
brother made trying to show everyone
that I wasn't going to be that child the
daughter of immigrants who fell in the
ditch and after all that struggle I was
completely worn out I didn't have it in
me anymore to keep pressing forward the
fact that I at last throwing my hands up
made me in my own eyes a total fuck-up
but in Lorraine's view it made me a
human being one who deserved to be here
whether or not I did another right thing
that day pick yourself up and try again
was a revelation
Our Lives try to get our attention and
countless ways through our gut instincts
through our loved ones through our
circumstances and in my case through an
angel guide once sent to me at exactly
the right juncture Lorraine showed up in
my life when I urgently needed a friends
and helped me see the truth she did that
and it was all that she could do because
I'd reached that place we all get to
where no amount of compassion or love or
hand-holding from someone else can
change things it was on me as I've done
on that rooftop I had to close my eyes
and make a choice that I wanted better
for myself in November 2009
one year after from this world to the
next I made a couple moves first I let
go of a delusion of a career in law like
I said I wasn't a good student and then
I enrolled in acting in an acting course
I bought some casting and finally I got
head shots taken if it's one thing
doesn't work move on to the next so
being miserable in one thing so that was
about this wonderful revelation through
the help of Lorraine and you are you are
so grateful I've heard you express it
for these key people who came along in
your life and helped you reach within
yourself get get rid of the binge
drinking the binge partying the thought
that you could be a lawyer yeah forget
that yeah and be yourself yeah yeah I
couldn't yeah well you know when when
someone is telling you that you don't
belong I mean I don't know if anyone has
insecurities and fitting in and and and
being loved I didn't feel any other
things I felt like I was nothing I felt
like I wasn't enough because my parents
were gone because I had all these
obstacles because I felt so deeply that
I wanted more and could could have more
but I didn't
all had a head of quite quite do that
so finding Lorraine was really great and
she told me that everything that I was
feeling was totally normal and and it
helped me see that I was just a human
being and that I belonged in this world
because I am a human being and I deserve
love
and I deserve a good education and I
deserve health care I serve all these
wonderful things that everybody else
gets AB so pick myself up and try it
again and I think that that journey took
you to Spain where your mother was
living yes and there in the time that
you spent with her those few days I
think it was a couple of weeks yeah it
seemed like three weeks there was
another revelation and if you could read
that one that let's go there because I
think this clears the past and the
vision but it starts with your
relationship with your mother and that
was a yeah it was I was I was very angry
at my mother and we didn't get along I
mean it was I mean you heard me say we
had a fight the day that she was taken
away we fought a lot anyway here we
prepared here we go I hadn't expected
the trip to be a hallmark reunion but it
was more difficult than I thought it
would be just as my mother had changed
so had I and that meant we clashed quite
a bit when you haven't seen someone in
years you have to literally relearn the
person figure out what makes him or her
angry scared kicked off and as we made
those adjustments silly tensions arose
diam your food is getting cold that
sounds a little bit rushing
okay it's still early for me I'm a rock
star Diane your food is getting cold
mommy would direct can you not tell me
what to do I should back I'm not a kid
anymore the tens of days went on she
frequently wanted to reminisce about my
childhood about the old days you
remember how you used to play out in the
backyard with Jana and Gabriella while I
was cooking she asked of course I do I
snapped but that was a long time ago
money and her mind died those
experiences were as vivid as they happen
the day before and as I drifted further
from her she held those memories all the
closer and more tightly but for me the
recollections were like old faded photos
ones I long since replaced with all the
moments that came after mommy knew
little of that life and her mention of
the previous one we shared brought up so
much anguish for me some of our moments
together might have been tough but many
others were sweet my musii I call my
mother she loved that during her time
together I made her laugh by taking on a
Spanish accent and imitating people
around us we took selfies around the
city it was just me and Mama I would
make up little sketches on the street
where I would pretend to be a Spanish
reporter interviewing her about whatever
monument or church who were in front of
slowly my memory of all the great times
we chaired began to come back even
though even when I was little my mother
would indulge all my kooky shenanigans
and let me play with her for hours I
remember I loved you and you loved me I
was your little girl and you were my
favorite we filled our evenings with
conversation but seldom on any subject
too painful for me to confront she had
figured out that I wasn't ready to
discuss anything it was still too raw
for me
that changed four nights before the end
of my trip over a bottle of Pinot Grigio
yeah that happens the two of us that
near each other on on the couch and it
was the first time I ever shared a drink
with my mother mommy a little tipsy
started talking about the deportation
that whole time was so horrible for me
she said the prison was dirty I couldn't
communicate with your father I couldn't
eat or sleep if she spoke my blood
pressure rose i sat up and I cut her off
you know what money I shouted I don't
want to hear another thing about how
hard things were for you mommy caught
off guard by my anger stood what are you
talking about Johnny you don't even know
how hard things were for me
I shouted it's always about you isn't it
you you you tears came pouring out you
abandoned me I have standing to hold on
Oh guys it's my time it up alright
wonderful I'm so rude I like don't care
I wrote book kidding I know someone's
know someone help me with it we're going
to talk about her volunteer works you
can see the other nice side of her I'm a
terrible human being yeah all this yeah
all of us to learn I was a terrible
human being at the elevator yeah take
that America all right you're worthy
yelling at yelling at my mom more two
more beautiful things about me again
um you abandoned me I have standing to
point my finger right at her face the
words ones I've never uttered aloud came
from some unknown place inside me with a
fire and airy that surprised me you
destroyed our family
I scream I hate you mommy widened her
eyes and then all at once she began to
cry she tried to pull me in her arms and
I resisted but I was weeping so hard I
couldn't keep my body skipped I finally
gave in to her pull and buried my face
in her bosom Diane I never wanted to
leave you mommy wailed I did everything
I could to stay with you everything I
never meant to hurt you mommy embraced
me for the longest time rubbing my back
and playing me from side to side as if I
was again her baby I'm so sorry she
whispered please forgive me I spent
nearly a decade making her wrong I blame
her for deserting me for taking the
kinds of chances that put her at greater
risk for deportation for banishing from
my life at the very moment when I most
craved her love her care and her
attention and on that afternoon when I
watched her wave goodbye through the bad
bars of paddy wagon I made a choice when
I wasn't conscious of
and the quietness of my heart I decided
that no apology mommy could ever offer
would be sufficient no explanation would
be enough for me to let go of the
deepest bitter of the deep bitterness
toward her that I carried in my belly
I built the barrier from that rage a
partition so thick and so high that no
one could ever peer round it my mother
might have left that Detention Center in
2001 but four years after I held her a
prisoner the person most responsible for
my heart aches I'd rendered her
unforgivable and in doing so I'd also
locked away myself a part of my soul and
any hope that she and I ever would ever
live at peace that night in the dim
light of my mother's living room I made
a choice to free us both on my last day
in might've a mummy drove me with her to
the mummy drove me with her to the farm
when she turned on the radio a familiar
ballad from pretty on cuspidor called
what a mob Neffe I don't know if anybody
knows priests and Goss at all o-tama
Megan came on and after we sang it
together for a half minute I stopped
what's the matter mommy asked me nothing
I said what is it she fries that song
takes me back I told her before she was
deported for the last time mommy would
often spruce up my bedroom just to make
things nice for me I come home from
school and find yummy burning candles
flickering and some have a little
present leading when afternoon I spotted
a fast photos customer CD movie that
seems way more propped up on my pillow I
fell in love with that album and I
listened to it so often that I almost
broken until we heard gosta song on the
radio I'd nearly forgotten mommy's gift
all those years earlier I carefully
buried away the memory along with
countless others I've missed you so much
mommy I told her I've missed you too
darling she
I cried the whole flight home the sweet
old woman seated next to me kept handing
the tissues
it's okay here she repeated everything
will be fine
these were tears of sadness they were
tears of relief a freedom of healing of
recognition my mother had been dealt a
whole hand of wild cards in life she'd
play them as well as she could and in
doing so she managed something far
braver than I ever might have attempted
at her age I had not yet learned fully
to accept my reality as she had been
forced to even still my mother has never
been a bitter person I'm amazed at her
great spirit and her ability to soldier
on in any challenge that life presents
with her presenter with a heart still
should I stop there specifically that's
a good scrape late to stop it but it is
unlike my reading skills are like
dwindling down on like that so now we're
going to we're going to take her to the
president we do want to leave time for
QA but what's so exciting about this
journey that you shared in your book I'm
lightheaded is your activism now and
here we are four days three days from an
election can't wait till it's over
but you have a chance to be involved in
such a important issue that we hear in
the political back-and-forth yeah your
last chapter is called call to action
yes what would you share with us
audience where is your challenge to call
the action to everyone who stood here
today well my fellow Texans
[Laughter]
well my call to action it's just well
like here's the thing before any of this
before all of my team and all of that
came from you know a lack of of knowing
anything you know I was I was so scared
of the word immigration that I forgotten
to educate myself and what this the
immigration system looked like in our
country why it was so difficult for my
parents
to find a path for citizenship why they
couldn't get their lives together and
why the lawyers that we had hired
scammed us and I I asked all these
questions but I never wanted to answer
them and so a few years back when I
started my acting career and I was being
asked all these questions that like
what's your favorite lipstick and I was
like oh honey love by Matt you know I
also came this this burning inside me
because I wasn't being honest about who
I was and and my life and also what I
wanted to change and and also just the
deep fear that other families were going
through the same thing that I was um
so I decided to share my story and
become politically active and honestly
it was the most freeing thing that I've
ever done and as as anyone living
anywhere you have a responsibility to
take care of you and your family in your
future and also your community and the
people around you and as misunderstood
as you are and as much as people don't
understand you or don't even side with
you and your political views or whether
you should even be here Thank You
fortunes amendment um you you have a
responsibility to for yourself to bring
your story out and make people
understand and and to bring people
together um that was ultimately your
call to action I am a call to action so
um so I was I was determined to be part
of this movement to never see families
go through what I went through and my
family went through because you know my
parents are like getting old and I'm
still here and I've been living without
them for a very long time and we've
missed out on so much and so I'm part of
this movement and I want immigration
reform in this country not just for
people of folks that have been through
what I've been through but for all of us
I don't think it's a very good system
it's outdated is it's inadequate and I
and I and I I made about to join a fight
and I'm excited and I hope that I hope
that things are okay November 8th and
the right woman is in office I know I
never tried to like I mean I have I have
the white who I care about who I want to
see enough that I my my focus has been
to to help those communities that often
feel like they don't have a voice and
often feel like what hey what am I going
to do what it would it would have my
vote doesn't matter to get those
communities to participate to see that
hey you are part of you are part of this
process and it's it's on you to join in
not you know for you and your family so
that that has been my journey is getting
people out to vote getting people to
participate getting people to you know
be involved because first of all it's
fun it's fun and it's great and to live
with purpose and so you find out so many
things about you that you never knew you
like figure out that you're actually
pretty smart
I find out that you're empathetic and
that you love people and you know you
you love human beings and you want to
make the world a better place and
there's nothing wrong with that well
thank you for that call to action I
think you've got some volunteers here if
you have a question and you want to come
to the microphone we only have time for
two but if you do we will gladly take
them now and and while you're gathering
your thoughts just so you know this is
not Diane's only opportunity here she'll
be at the book signing time when we
conclude which is right down the street
and then later this afternoon at the
odesi tent she'll be there it's the
grand éxito panel talking about success
in her career so if there are no
questions then thank you all for being
here today
oh okay and I know you read the book
right let's get ready [ __ ] okay you
ready but then Hank you're wrong
hey girl you read it in Spanish Oh Jane
I love you here I should kindergarten in
Fort Worth and all of my students are
the children of immigrants and I just
wanted to ask any advice that I'm not
I'm not a solid immigrants but what
advice would you give me tonight why
aren't you though
well eventually yeah yeah but I don't
know I don't experience the same I hear
you all say I do okay I just want to
film what would you say to me to empower
them um we'll share this book with them
um well I would say just to you know
make sure that you're teaching them
about you know our history right and
like and what really is going on
I Roberta the wonderful woman who picked
me up I had this great book and I like
don't know the title now so I don't even
know I'm referencing it right it talked
about all the lies my teacher told me I
think I think it's that otherwise might
be preserving so I think that educating
your kids and what our history really
looks like because I think knowing your
history is so empowering knowing where
they they come from and just times
they're enough but they're enough but
obviously if their child with immigrants
teaching them about the immigration
system and what our struggles are and
what the different movements are and
what the obstructionists look like and
what the 1996 laws look like things like
that but yeah thank you so much writers
are a big round of applause please for
Diane Guerrero
talking to my time
thank you thank you all for being here
and enjoy the rest of the Book Festival
[Applause]
are you a medium okay
I'm going to take one with a flash
class is like a lifesaver
how
those guys
you're talking to people over there
[Applause]
there
then you're watching book TV on c-span
to live coverage of the Texas Book
Festival in downtown Austin in a few
minutes
Clint Hill will be speaking the former
Secret Service Officer will be talking
about his book and his career serving
under five presidents now for a complete
schedule of our coverage today go to
book TV or
and now while we wait for the Texas Book
Festival to resume we want to show you a
little bit from an interview we did with
the University of Texas professor on a
recent visit to Austin
yeah
[Applause]
and potentially American is to believe
that people can come together to make
the world a better place and that it can
be done in a representative